>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Sarah Burnes: Hello, everybody.
Thank you for coming to our panel,
Authorship in the Digital Age.
I am Sarah Burnes, a DPLA Board
member and what we're going to do
for the next 45 minutes is
I will introduce these guys.
Then I have a series
of questions for them.
I hope that they will start talking
and squabbling amongst themselves
and we'll do that for about
half an hour and then we'll open
up the floor to you
for your questions.
So, introductions.
On my very left is Robin Sloan.
He grew up in Detroit, went
to school at Michigan State
where he co-founded a literary
magazine called Oats .
He has worked at Poynter
Current TV and Twitter,
and at all those places his
jobs had to do with something
about the future of media.
He is also the author of Mr.
Penumbra's 24-Hour Bookstore ,
which I had the very great
pleasure of helping to bring
out into the world, and actually
started as a short story published
on -- was that KDP
Kindle Direct Publishing?
>> Craig Mod: It was, it was.
>> Sarah Burnes: Yeah, KDP.
>> Craig Mod: Back when that
was still kind of weird.
>> Sarah Burnes: Right,
yes, exactly, exactly.
And I checked yesterday.
We have actually -- that
book has been published now
in 30 other countries which
is really very exciting.
And he lives in the Bay Area.
Virginia Heffernan writes
regularly about digital culture
for the New York Times Magazine .
She is also the author of the
completely wonderful cult novel,
The Underminer which she wrote
with her extremely
funny friend Mike Albo
which I recommend you get
if you haven't read it.
She holds a PhD in English
Literature from Harvard
and has a new book
coming out called Magic
and Loss which I've just
finished, and it really,
actually changed the way I
thought about the Internet.
She looks at it, not just merely
as technology or a business tool,
but as a piece of art
in its own right,
and then applies critical
tools in looking at it.
And I really -- I think it's going
to blow your mind [laughter].
And she lives in Brooklyn near me.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yes.
>> Sarah Burnes: Then Craig
Mod is a writer, designer,
and photographer I think I'll say
who triangulates between Japan,
the Bay Area, and New York City.
He's written for The Atlantic,
the New Scientist, the New Yorker,
Virginia Quarterly Review, and
the New York Times among lots
of other publications,
and then also online.
And I really recommend
that you go to his website
and I think you'll probably spend a
lot of time there reading his essays
because they're fascinating and have
actually just been published in 2015
in Japan and in Korea,
is that right?
>> Robin Sloan: Right.
>> Sarah Burnes: So his essays are
on topics as varied as walking,
which he loves to do, sushi,
but also on publishing,
especially e-book and app design,
design in the digital space.
So just very briefly about myself.
I am a literary agent
at the Gernert Company.
I represent fiction writers,
adult and children's fiction
writers, and non-fiction writers.
I spent some time on the, what
we call the publishing side
of publishing which is
on the editorial side.
And when I -- my first job in
publishing I worked on a typewriter
and we did out P&Ls with
a calculator and a pencil,
so this is -- we have come
a long way since those days.
So I wanted to start
at the beginning
which is actually the
creative process
because of a suit I've
always been really fascinated
by the creative process
and where ideas happen
and how they get executed and a book
for a long time was one single
consciousness onto a page.
The digital world has really changed
that and sort of what is created
and for whom and how and how fast.
Its speed is something that I've
talked to many of you guys about.
And so, Craig, actually, I
thought we would start with you --
>> Craig Mod: Okay.
>> Sarah Burnes: --
because you wanted to talk
about fast and weird books --
>> Craig Mod: Yeah.
>> Sarah Burnes: -- and
I'm interested in that,
sort of how those are created
and how they then get
out into the world.
>> Craig Mod: Yeah, yeah.
So a lot of the essays
that I've worked
on online actually have
been really slow weirdly.
So an idea will hold and I'll
kind of sit on it for six months
or for a year and then finally I'll
realize, ah okay, now I know how
to write about that thing.
>> Sarah Burnes: Right.
>> Craig Mod: Or I'll write --
like when I did a Kickstarter
for the book Art Space Tokyo ,
the proposal for the Kickstarter
was written in September
and then the Kickstarter
happened the next May.
>> Sarah Burnes: Is that
because the project itself --
>> Craig Mod: It was
just kind of prep
so I think the interesting thing
about digital is you can kind
of like dip a toe in really
quickly and then you can --
I like to take a step back.
>> Sarah Burnes: Right.
>> Craig Mod: So this when I did the
Kickstarter was back when you had
to get permission to
do the Kickstarter.
So like you're e-mailing
the founders
of Kickstarter saying I have
this cool think I want to do.
Is it cool if I do it?
And then they vet it and they
read it and they go okay, yeah,
we're going to let you do it.
And so I got the permission and
then eight months later it was
like all right, now
we can finally do it.
I feel like we're ready.
But fast books -- so as you
said, I've been slightly obsessed
with walks over the
last couple of years.
>> Sarah Burnes: He writes
wonderfully about walking.
>> Craig Mod: So in Japan I live
mainly in Tokyo and Japan has a lot
of beautiful pilgrimage
walks that are, you know,
these paths that are a thousand
years old or 1200 years old,
and they're really accessible,
and they're really
easy to do these walks.
And I've done 10 or 11
in the last three years.
And the last one I did was
just two weeks ago and I pulled
out Dan Rubin who's a great
photographer and another friend
of mine, and the three of us
did this walk for eight days
and it's called [foreign words].
It's one of the old
pilgrimage routes.
And the goal was -- Dan and I
had wanted to do a book together
for a while, a photography
kind of collection,
and I said, all right, Dan.
Let's do this walk and then we're
going to hide in a house for a week,
this house in the countryside
that a friend of mine lent to us.
It was old, it was freezing,
it was a 150-year-old sort
of Meiji era Japanese sort of
mayor's house that was kind
of converted, being
converted into an inn.
And we took it over.
We mailed a printer to the house.
And I love -- Robin knows
I love this printer.
Sarah knows I love this printer.
Brother laser printers are
one of my favorite things.
>> Sarah Burnes: Write
it down, everyone.
>> Craig Mod: They're incredible.
They're like $80.
They kind of last forever.
You can buy cheap toner
if you look online.
You don't have to buy
the real stuff.
And we just blew through like six
toners in this old Japanese house.
And we printed out all
the photos we took.
It was like 3000 photos.
And then we just started curating.
And the goal was we had five days
to go through all these photos
from this walk we had
just done, meditate on it,
come up with some subset,
and then make that a book.
And we did.
We finished last Saturday,
so just a few days ago.
And it's done.
We have the whole book done.
And now we're just negotiating
with blurb to get some quotes
on slightly special
printing for print-on-demand.
But the whole thing -- the goal's,
the whole thing is from experience
to shipping a book globally where
we take on as little of the onus
of kind of warehousing and dealing
with shipping logistics as possible,
but still produce a beautiful
thing, a beautiful artifact.
The goal is to do that
within about a month.
And I think we're going to hit that.
>> Sarah Burnes: Wow.
>> Craig Mod: That's pretty fast.
>> Sarah Burnes: Will
there be an e-book as well?
>> Craig Mod: There's
going to be a website.
>> Sarah Burnes: A website.
>> Craig Mod: No e-book, yeah.
>> Sarah Burnes: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: Yeah.
No, really, don't really know how to
shape an e-book around this stuff,
and it's a lot of work, and it
feels like the payoff isn't --
I don't find the payoff
to be quite there.
So we're going to make a --
we have this beautiful template for
a website where that maps the route.
As you scroll you can kind
of see where we walked --
>> Sarah Burnes: Oh,
that's [inaudible].
>> Craig Mod: -- and all the photos.
As I was walking I run
this program called Moves.
It's an old app that
was bought by Facebook.
It still runs.
It's constantly running
in the background.
And what you can do is, if
I'm shooting with a camera
that doesn't have GPS data my Moves
is recording GPS data 24-hours-a-day
of me, which is kind of creepy
but also kind of cool [laughter].
Our three years of data.
I can literally import this
into Google Maps or Google Earth
and walk through, have Google Earth
fly me through the last three years
of my life, street by street.
>> Sarah Burnes: Wow.
>> Craig Mod: Which is
like weirdly compelling.
And so we're able to layer
this data on top of the photos
and so we have pretty
precise GPS data for,
and elevation data
for all the images.
So we map that onto a map,
do a little JavaScript,
and as you scroll it does
this beautiful thing.
It shows you the photos and
shows you where we were.
So it's kind of a -- it's
a nice artifact, too.
>> Sarah Burnes: That's very cool.
>> Robin Sloan: Craig, when you,
actually before you embarked
on this walk, when you were
imagining starting this project,
it sounds like you had
a vision of this book,
and it might have been
a blurry vision.
You didn't know how
thick it was going to be
or you certainly didn't know what
the contents were going to be.
But you like, you could kind of
see that shadowy form, right?
>> Craig Mod: A little
bit, yeah, yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: I mean, I think it's
-- to this question of creativity
and where do these projects start,
where do writing projects starts
in the year 2016, there's this kind
of way of thinking about stories
and content that you sometimes hear.
You hear it in, you know,
newsrooms or from some of these new
like multimedia companies
that aspire
to produce content on all platforms.
And they'll say something --
>> Sarah Burnes: Synergy.
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah.
I'm going to make a contention
here, and I'm curious to know
if it resonates with you two at all
because you might have actually very
different ideas or different kind
of temperaments in this regard.
What you often hear is, you
know what we need to do?
We need to like take
an idea and then find
like the best medium
to express it in.
And I think that is a lie.
I think that is not how
things emerge in the world.
>> Sarah Burnes: That's not
the way my understanding --
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah.
>> Sarah Burnes: That's not
the way we think about it.
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah, right?
Like -- and, I mean, you can --
I guess you can hypothetically
image how someone would go
through that process
and arrive at like
that would make a great
picture book.
But it has no actual
correspondence to the way that any
of my projects have ever emerged.
I mean, you mention the short
story version of this thing
that later became a novel.
The reason it existed -- I mean,
this is the truth, the ground truth.
Craig and I both have sort of a
romance with the Kindle screen,
the tactile properties of a Kindle
screen, and just the way it looks.
It's kind of weird.
And it was my enchantment with
that screen, my first experiences
with it, that made me
want to write something
for that screen, to
be on that screen.
So the format and like
literally the material
in a very real way called
forth the story, the writing.
And that's been the case.
You can just get in the line
for almost everything I've been
produced; I mean I produced.
>> Sarah Burnes: Can you
talk a little bit about
"Julie Rubicon" and how that --
>> Robin Sloan: I mean, yeah.
Well, that's the bookend.
Yeah, that's the -- there's
been all these examples
of things along the way.
And the most recent was a
story that I wrote for Facebook
on Facebook, and it was not me.
This was just, you know, you
can find it on my Facebook page.
It's free to read [laughter], and it
was -- again, it grew out of the --
not a sense of like
I've got a story.
You know, like what, what?
Who just has a story
they want to tell?
I don't even know what that means.
>> Sarah Burnes: Right.
>> Robin Sloan: Instead it was
a fascination with this medium,
you know, the Facebook Note
as a think in the world,
and the way seeing how they spread
and seeing them kind of filter
into my own feed and thinking,
damn, that's interesting, you know?
This is just like the esthetics of
it and sort of the assumptions built
into it, and the kind of things
that get written as Facebook Notes,
that like a little bit like
okay, it's 10 o'clock at night.
I probably shouldn't
be writing this,
but [laughter] I think I'm
going to write it anyway.
Publish. And so that,
starting from that,
I sort of developed this whole story
that became this weird sci-fi thing
and then became something that I --
it was my first foray
into Facebook publishing.
But, again, it's, for me at
least, it begins with form.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Mm-hmm.
>> Sarah Burnes: It
begins with form.
That's interesting.
Virginia, you have spoken in
other contexts about hyperlexia
that we're sort of inflicted with.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Mm-hmm.
>> Sarah Burnes: Is it
fair to say that we are?
And some of it is because the
east of that kind of publishing --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Sarah Burnes: -- of the even
just put something up on Facebook.
And so they're -- so, but it's also
true that you said that, you know,
"The Internet," I'm going
to quote you, "is the latest
and most powerful extension
and expression
of the project of being human."
So how -- could you just talk a
little bit about that, about what --
tell these guys what hyperlexia
is and how you see it, but then,
sort of how to -- I guess
the question is then,
how do we manage it?
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
So the idea of hyperlexia is
that we're reading too much,
we're reading all the time.
And we just heard the Education
Panel talk a little bit
about the digital divide and
concerns about failing literacy.
But we're in a society that
finds reading so intoxicating
that we won't even
stop driving to --
we'll risk highway
fatalities in order
to keep reading and writing texts.
And I think in some ways the ease
of publishing is in fact a response
to the, you know, crabbed difficulty
of writing in the 20th century.
The heyday of writer's block,
the heyday of the New Yorker ,
that if you didn't squeeze something
into the New Yorker in the
so-called lapidary style,
like it's etched in
stone, where every --
I remember growing up with the idea
that every comma was sweated over,
that if you were a real
writer you spent, you know,
you spent all this time on your
M dashes and your, you know.
And like a spelling error
would be, you know, a --
it's some kind of psychological
crisis.
>> Sarah Burnes: Robin
has just recently written
about M dashes I believe
actually [laughter].
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Sarah Burnes: Anyway,
sorry to interrupt.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Not at all.
And, you know, we're in a very
typo-friendly culture now,
gaff-friendly culture now.
I just wrote something
about Trump and Twitter.
Well, let me back up and say
that following on, you know,
following on Craig's being
inspired by the idea of, you know,
publishing -- making
this book really quickly,
and Robin's skepticism about
whether we all have a story to tell
and we're just looking
for the medium.
You know, we all heard
the expression
"The medium is the message," and
sort of either thought it was opaque
or just, you know,
mystification, or it sunk in.
But some of us decided
to take it seriously
and just kind of live by it.
And I think that that is like,
you know, part of the project
of being me is to say there is no
Trump without Twitter, you know?
There is no Robin's book
without the Kindle screen.
Like it just -- you, you know,
are working back from that and,
you know, to get a little abstract,
the technology is speaking
us, you know?
And that was -- so back
to the New Yorker .
You know, one of the points that
students of 20th century poetry say
of me is that 19th century, the
long line, the sort of Whitman line,
and that effusive style,
suddenly became --
because you had to
sell an ad against it
in the New Yorker and also
run a poem against non-fiction,
against spot art, and so forth,
and cartoons, they became short.
And once they became short,
you just built this bottleneck
that like the hardest
thing in the world was
to overcome your writer's
block, you know,
the New Yorker writers
famously like retreat
and they can't get anything done for
20 years, and that's real writing.
And fake writing --
and so, I really --
you know, I grew up largely online.
This, you know, accident
of network computing meant
that in the ARPANET era, as a child,
I got online at Dartmouth College
and was playing like D&D-style
games, like kids, you know,
like kids now except
that it was 1979.
I knew that there was that
kind of writing and reading,
but that was false writing and
reading because it was like close
to TV and it was just bad
somehow because it was masquerade,
because you were --
you know, I was nine.
I was pretending to be 18.
Not to find predators but to --
although I was probably open
to a little of that [laughter].
But I also was -- I wanted to
be able for people to mistake me
for someone who could
talk coherently
about Reaganomics [laughter].
Okay. And I couldn't -- in
the classroom I, you know,
like didn't have a leg to stand
on to talk about the Cold War or,
you know, later, Reaganomics.
But online I did, you know?
And I wasn't especially
comfortable in physical space.
And all of a sudden I was
comfortable like writers forever,
on the page, with language,
with symbols, and so forth.
So that was happening on one level,
and on the other level I wanted
to be a poet and what I knew of
poetry was the New Yorker poem.
And what I knew of that was
that it was just so hard,
that you would get -- you know,
the ideal writer's story was you
got 50 rejections and then you,
you know, finally got this
one poem in or three poems in.
And so those two things sat
uneasily with each other.
There was this digital
world of like proliferation.
You know, YouTube appeared
and all of a sudden it was
like everybody had
just been waiting.
It was almost like a
civilization was unearthed instead
of an art form started.
It was like everybody had been
waiting to post four-minute videos.
And all of a sudden, you know,
just huge numbers of them went up.
And then, also, these
polyglot comments.
And the YouTube Comment
Section is like notorious
for being rabbley [assumed
spelling] and it's just, you know,
whatever you think of
mobs, you probably think
of the YouTube comment section.
On the other hand supremely literate
like hybrids of Asian languages
and English and like, you know,
emoticons and I don't know
if you can use emoji
or whatever now in --
>> Robin Sloan: Oh, yeah.
>> -- YouTube comments.
But -- so that and the beginning
of Web 2.0 I was like oh,
that's strange literacy that
I remember from our, you know,
Dungeons and Dragons meets
Reaganomics meets -- I don't know.
There was a lot of like damsels and
steeds and Led Zeppelin that sort
of influenced our language in
the '70s online [laughter].
And --
>> Robin Sloan: Wait, computers.
There was a while when every
computer server was named Gandalf.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Oh, yeah.
Yes, exactly.
>> Robin Sloan: Like
every university --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Exactly.
>> Robin Sloan: -- it
was that you could tell.
It was the same of the analog of
the same person at every university.
It was like just go.
Virginia, just like set
up the server, so like --
>> Virginia Heffernan:
Yeah, Gandalf.
>> Robin Sloan: -- don't
mind if I do [laughter].
Small.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
[Inaudible] totally.
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
For some reason that was like where
you lived and that's another medium
as a message thing is that,
you know, these token worlds,
Star Trek and so forth that
formed all these communities really
like when they found tech in
another idiom, the Grateful Dead,
when the found tech they were just
like where have you been
all my life, you know?
It was like -- I think,
doesn't your husband write
about self-digitizing communities?
Or at least he spoke to me about --
>> Sarah Burnes: He
may well [laughter].
>> Virginia Heffernan:
Like something --
but it was like something
about like the Greeks being
somehow self-digitizing.
I mean, it -- this
is beyond my brain.
But, you know, that in ancient times
there were cultures that almost
like presaged or acted
digitally before digital.
So, anyway.
Those things all interest me.
>> Sarah Burnes: We'll
get him here next year.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Okay, good.
When I discovered -- he might have
been telling me about another field
of study that he was -- anyway.
>> Sarah Burnes: Right,
right, right.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
But so I went to work
at the New Yorker as
a fact-checker and,
still while I was there,
before anything was online
and as a fact-checker it was
about, you know, very sharp pencils
in this red and graphitey
combination
where you were crossing out letters.
And, indeed, every
letter had to be checked
because we were keeping
alive that idea that,
you know, was supremely elitist.
That only we could do this
thing, and that we were
like had some unique
qualification to do it.
You know Craig brought up sushi
and you might have told me this
or maybe I learned it in Tokyo,
that in America we think sushi's
incredibly difficult to make
and you have to go through all these
guild procedures and like whatever.
And then when you sort of learn that
it's like raw fish and a little bit
of wasabi and so forth, you
think like why is this so hard?
Well, it's hard to bottleneck
it so that it's like, you know,
to keep a kind of guild
system alive so that you have
to like mop the floor for
a long time and it's all
that like wax on/wax
off thing so that you --
until you become Grand
Master of this thing.
And that's what I discovered
at the New Yorker , you know.
And so at the same time Slate and
all these online magazines were
appearing and it was just
like write it, you know?
I just like wrote something
really fast.
It went up online.
There were 500 comments.
I remember one of them was, "Does
your mother have any children
who don't have brain
damage [laughter]?"
And Andrew's fine.
My parents are here.
My brother is fine
[laughter], but --
and I was like this is so
different from this, you know,
world that was the real
literacy, the real literacy.
One thing I say in the book is that
reading scrolls, Torah scrolls,
you know, was for scribes only.
And, you know, one of the
innovations of the Roman Empire was
to create the codex, the --
you know, what we recognize
as a book now.
Those were supposed to be
illiterate because they were
so easy to find your place in.
It was because they had pages
that broke it down for you.
That's not even real reading.
Real reading you have
to supply the vowels.
You have to like keep your eye --
finding your place was what
only certain people could do.
So, you know, it is amazing to
me, and it was a great panel
in Education, but it's amazing
to me to hear people talk
about how we have to cultivate
this literacy that can
like only happen here at the Library
of Congress when, you know --
I mean, we're creating
entirely new languages
of this like incredible speed.
I mean it's so far beyond emoji's,
like anyone -- it can't be easier.
It's probably equally hard to learn
Ancient Hebrew as it is to learn
like really high-speed
use of gifs --
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah,
yeah [laughter].
>> Virginia Heffernan: -- you know?
I don't understand --
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah, yeah.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
-- you know, you set --
you're like halfway through
typing Wolfman Jack into a --
you know, something.
And some one [pooh]
comes with a gif.
It's like they read your mind.
>> Robin Sloan: And it's for the --
and it's like the product
of a gif sommelier.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
Yeah [laughter].
>> Robin Sloan: It's so totally --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Totally.
>> Robin Sloan: -- tuned to the --
Remember Neil Dash was like -- he
can find a link so quickly on Slack.
Like --
>> Robin Sloan: Well, some people --
well, you know, some people
like keep gif stashes.
I think that's --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yes.
>> Robin Sloan: --
that's the real --
the real high level thing
is that you have a --
if you're using your computer,
you actually have a
folder on your desktop --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yes.
>> Robin Sloan: -- and it's
like spring-loaded
[chu-chu], ready to go.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: I'm curious.
It's so -- it's amazing to hear
you talk about that sort of --
this new endlessness and
this new kind of profusion,
and it makes me realize that for all
I know about your opinions, Craig,
about the way these things work,
I don't actually know how you feel
about that -- like the
endlessness, the profusion.
I know you love edges.
>> Craig Mod: I love edges.
>> Robin Sloan: I know you are,
but I know you love things,
I know you love things
that can be finished.
>> Craig Mod: I do, yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: Like --
>> Craig Mod: Well, yeah,
I think it's important.
>> Robin Sloan: And so, I mean it
might be worth talking about that
for a second because that's
certainly relevant to, again,
you know, thinking about
what you're going to produce
and how it's going to be packaged.
But does the like whomp of YouTube
or whatever -- does it like --
>> Virginia Heffernan:
Oh, the whole thing.
>> Robin Sloan: -- does it make
you like scared or ecstatic?
>> Virginia Heffernan: I think
it makes everybody scared.
I mean, I think it's -- would
be to say that the, you know,
when you first -- I
mean, I had a fantasy,
I think a lot of people did,
that like one day I would kind
of read every book that existed.
And the first time I saw Google it
was like this Faustian overwhelm,
like I'll never be
as smart as Google.
And I was defeated on the first day,
like Kasparov lost to
Deep Blue at chess.
I lost my will to play.
>> Robin Sloan: Over it.
>>
>> Craig Mod: But back in the
beginning when it was just Yahoo,
it was almost doable, right?
>> Virginia Heffernan: Right.
But there was a time --
>> Craig Mod: It was
like, it was like you --
>> Virginia Heffernan: --
there was a time when you --
>> Craig Mod: -- you could
look at it and go, ah --
>> Virginia Heffernan:
-- first thought --
>> Craig Mod: Yeah, I could do this.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
Yeah. But there's -- for
all of us, there's a moment,
this thing is too big
to be read, you know?
My moral choices are often
about choosing not to read.
>> Craig Mod: Well,
my greatest sadness
as a child was realizing I wasn't
going to be allowed to see 2100.
>> Robin Sloan: Mm.
>> Craig Mod: Like I
got to have this --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: -- I have
like this moment in a car --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: -- where I went,
"I cant wait to see 2100.
And like how many years is that?"
It was like, "Wait a
minute" [laughter].
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: "I'm not
going to be able -- like" --
and so my whole fantasy
of heaven was a VCR
that allowed me like
go through time.
>> Robin Sloan: Hmm.
>> Craig Mod: Yeah.
>> Virginia Heffernan: And get
your move -- get your move --
>> Craig Mod: Get my move is data.
Yeah. No. But, no,
the overall -- I'm --
>> Virginia Heffernan:
That's the heavenly cloud.
>> Craig Mod: I am beyond
being over -- I'm just excited.
I love --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: -- YouTube
is one of my favorite --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: -- things
in the world now.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
Incredible resource.
>> Craig Mod: I am so
obsessed with YouTube.
I have -- and mainly in part because
they've done a really good job
of subscriptions, with being
able to draw boundaries
around the craziness
of it, of exploring.
Like the YouTube apps on IOS and
iPad are really phenomenal now.
They're like some of
the best apps out there.
>> Sarah Burnes: Are
you making any videos?
Are you doing --
>> Craig Mod: No, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
It's a -- video is
like it's so much --
that's the thing I feel like
could still be optimized.
It's like the ease of
making video is not nearly
as easy as it is to do text.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: To do the comments.
That said, Snapchat, I've
been using the heck out,
and I only do video on Snapchat.
>> Sarah Burnes: You
and my children.
>> Craig Mod: That's --
it's actually really fun.
And that ephemerality --
I mean, Robin, I know you're
a Twitter deletionist.
>> Robin Sloan: Mm-hmm.
>> Craig Mod: The idea of like
not having things stick around,
not having the like archive is
kind of compelling in a weird way.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
Oh, yeah, yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: And but so
-- but let me sharpen my --
>> Craig Mod: Sure.
>> Robin Sloan: -- spear point --
>> Craig Mod: Yes.
>> Robin Sloan: -- a
little bit [laughter].
As a author --
>> Craig Mod: Yes.
>> Robin Sloan: -- as someone who
is creating things in this world,
and so not just as sort of
a consumer or an enjoyer,
but as like someone who
wants, like you want,
people to have this
book and enjoy it.
Does the, you know, flinging it
into this world that is suddenly
like [inaudible] so much vaster?
Is that like -- how does that feel?
>> Sarah Burnes: You're
talking about the walking book.
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah.
I can --
>> Sarah Burnes: Yeah, yeah.
>> Craig Mod: Just like the
walking book, for example.
Yeah, yeah.
The --
>> Robin Sloan: You've
made something with edges
and you're throwing it
into edgeless space.
>> Craig Mod: Oh.
Well, I mean it's exciting, right?
Because with that edgelessness
comes access to people.
I mean, that's the
beauty of the Internet.
It's like you put a
thing up there and you --
potentially a billion
people can read it.
>> Robin Sloan: Mm-hmm.
>> Craig Mod: And that's
pretty exciting, you know?
And you just kind of have to deal
with this part and parcel of that --
>> Virginia Heffernan:
It is online --
>> Craig Mod: -- that bargain.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
It's online in PDF or?
>> Craig Mod: It's not up there yet.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Right.
>> Craig Mod: But people --
>> Virginia Heffernan: All right.
But it will be.
>> Craig Mod: That's [inaudible].
>> Virginia Heffernan:
But it will be.
>> Craig Mod: It will just
be -- it will be the website.
And, you asked if I was
going to do a digital book.
>> Sarah Burnes: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: I'd like --
the lines between what is
and what isn't a digital book, I
mean, are so fuzzy, in my opinion.
You know, is an EPUB
inherently the only way
to be a digital book is a PDF
suddenly then a digital book?
I mean, is taking a PDF of a
website then a digital book?
I feel like making a website can be
as much a digital book as an EPUB.
>> Sarah Burnes: Sure, absolutely.
>> Craig Mod: I mean EPUBS
are effectively websites.
>> Robin Sloan: Or a book, or a book
that you think can
acquire only online.
>> Craig Mod: Right.
>> Robin Sloan: I think there's
a lot of things like that.
Like there's a whole genre --
this is like something interesting
to note in the world --
a whole genre of the like
many generations now,
descendants of Dungeons
and Dragons --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: -- in
the role-playing game.
Kind of like --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: -- kind
of like deconstructed --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yes.
>> Robin Sloan: --
and built back up.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: And they're all
sold exclusively as like $5 PDF's.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yes,
the $5 PDF, absolutely.
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah, yeah.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yes, yes.
>> Craig Mod: Well, the
photography world is --
>> Virginia Heffernan: I'd
say, yeah, Tim Ferris thing.
It's like -- you know, Tim Ferris
like just thinks he should be able
to make your entire living
in four hours a week.
And he's just like the first
thing you need to get is a PDF
because people will pay to
download it and you, like --
>> Robin Sloan: How funny.
>> Virginia Heffernan: --
tease it and carnival bark it
in all these ways that
the secret is in this PDF.
And it will be three pages.
But one of the things
we're talking about,
this New Yorker thing is we
-- because we're writers --
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
-- we are, you know --
and an agent, like all
of us are determined
to jack up the value of --
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
-- what we do.
>> Craig Mod: But in terms of people
making money with digital books --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: -- the photography
community hasn't nailed it.
Like their guys just making
printing hundreds of thousands
of dollars a year selling
PDFs on how
to like use light room
[inaudible] --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Oh, yeah.
>> Craig Mod: -- or
do iPhone photography.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Right.
>> Craig Mod: Like the photography
world is so okay with PDFs.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Right.
>> Craig Mod: And there's
no other way to do it
because you need all these
screenshots and a PDF is
so much easier to make than an EPUB.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
Yeah, I get that.
>> Craig Mod: And anyone can do
it and they it up on their website
and they sell it using, you know,
Stripe or whatever, and it's just,
you know, they -- it's
just a download.
It's so effortless.
But more than any other community
I've seen the photography community
embrace the PDF.
It's like a true book, a true book
of like how to do photography.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Let me
tell you like a weird thing
about making books valuable again,
making content valuable again.
ACQUITY, the insurance company,
a couple of years ago decided
that they were going to
publish their annual report
in a pop-up book.
And pop-up books, including Pat the
Bunny and the massed produced ones,
all are made by hand.
There's no way -- I mean, they
make them in China but each one --
there's no machine
technology involved.
And what they did -- what it did,
because all the other annual
reports were circulated digitally,
some in PDFs and so forth,
was they created demand
for their annual report.
And they'd had a great year and
all of a sudden everyone wanted
to get their hands on the
ACQUITY Annual Report.
I mean, it was like, you know,
at some insurance whatever.
It was the talk of the whole thing.
And, you know -- and I also recently
talked to the lawyer for Scholastic
who kept the last J. K.
Rowling thing offline
until the release last
-- Harry Potter novel.
And it meant she had to be in like,
I don't know what they call them.
It's like the equivalent of clean
rooms or rubber rooms or something,
where there's no WiFi and they
had to like create computers
and printers and stuff that
never -- and no phones.
Nothing could have any WiFi access.
So it's like creating the
edges, creating the margins,
creating the like -- there can
only be 40 of these pop-up books.
And like you will, there
will never be a 50th.
And even if you took flat photos
of it, even if you whatever,
you can't make another one of these.
>> Craig Mod: Right.
Well, and I think the
proliferation of the infinitude
of the Internet has made these
things even more compelling, right?
>> Virginia Heffernan: Right, right.
>> Craig Mod: And that's
why I mean with our --
this photo book, for example, it's
like we can put most of the photos
up on Instagram but
without those edges.
And also just seeing photos big --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: -- is sort of
compelling in and of itself.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah, yep.
>> Craig Mod: Without
the edges, I don't know.
It's somehow -- I think people don't
take the time to really look at it.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: To really
give it a moment.
And so a pop-up book is --
>> Virginia Heffernan:
A good call, right?
>> Craig Mod: -- a super-powerful
way of doing that, yeah, yeah.
>> Sarah Burnes: So I've
gotten through about a quarter
of my questions here [laughter].
But I'd like to open
it up to you guys
because I'm sure you
have questions, too.
And if you don't, I'll
just keep going.
Are there questions out there?
Yes.
>> One of the first things
that attracted me to the work
of Craig was his fascination
with Japan, living in Japan.
And one of the things that
bothers me about the Internet is
that you're always worried --
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
-- you're going to see the
Internet in a different way.
So I wanted Craig to
talk a little bit
about what does the Internet look
like for a young person
in Japan right now?
What are they doing on social media?
What types of things
are they reading,
from a literary perspective?
>> Virginia Heffernan: From Myanmar.
>> Craig Mod: Well,
or Myanmar, yeah.
I just spent two months in
Myanmar at the end of last year.
Myanmar's fascinating just
because two years ago a SIM
for a cellphone cost $5000-ish, and
last year it went down to $1.50.
So it's a pretty big drop.
And then they opened up --
the government realized being a
military dictatorship wasn't helping
them much and they
started opening up markets.
Now there's 3G coverage
kind of all over the place.
And you have a bunch
of farmers sitting
on buffalo playing Clash Your Clans
[laughter] which is kind of cool.
Japan is funny, right?
I mean Japan -- a lot of times when
people talk about Japan and things
that come out of Japan, there's
this Galapagos phrase that's
thrown around.
The Galapagos keitei,
the Galapagos cellphones.
You know, Japan, if you went
to -- I moved to Japan in 2000.
You know the first cell
phone I got had a camera.
It was a color screen, it
was this clamshell thing.
I mean it felt magical.
I mean it really -- like there's
nothing else in the world like it.
And none of those cell phones
were exported because none
of them were built to work on, you
know, global sort of cell networks.
It could only work in Japan.
A lot of the functionality
they built
for it was only workable in Japan.
You could, you know, you
could use a cell phone to pay
for stuff at convenience stores.
But, of course, it
only worked in Japan.
It was all proprietary protocols.
The Internet on those
phones was called,
the DOCOMO Network
was called i-Mode,
so you weren't accessing
the open Internet.
You were accessing i-Mode.
And you had to like --
if you prostrated before the
DOCOMO gods maybe you got
in the i-Mode Menu.
If you got in the i-Mode Menu,
then you were a billionaire.
It's like -- there were all
these like weird gates to it.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Uh-huh.
>> Craig Mod: So the Internet
in Japan, and I'm by no means
like an expert on the Internet
in Japan, but it kind of evolved
in this weird way where in --
while we were embracing blogging
with our -- not with
pseudonyms, you know.
We were ourselves blogging.
Blogging became a thing where, you
know, Kettley and others said, oh,
hey, we can publish these folks.
This is to your point about this
being real literature or not,
being recognized as something
that can be made into book form
that should be out there.
These people should get a platform
outside of just the Internet.
Japan kind of evolved in
this kind of funky way.
And you had things like cell phone
novels which a lot of people point
to which, by the way,
is totally not a thing.
>> Sarah Burnes: So, yeah,
because American publishers
are totally fascinated
by that and want it --
>> Craig Mod: It's like --
>> Sarah Burnes: -- oh, we'll do it.
>> Craig Mod: -- for a millisecond.
So one wrote up -- wrote a novel on
a cell phone and like someone wrote
about it for the New York Times .
And that was it forever
and ever [laughter].
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: Japan is the -- like
there are two fallacies about Japan.
One is that it's technologically
advanced.
It's totally not.
Everyone faxes things and, you
know, you go into government offices
and it's like going back
into 1950 here in America.
And cell phones have not
really evolved at all either.
Everyone uses an iPhone now.
That was really weird.
iPhones sort of leapfrogging
everything in Japan much
to the sadness of Sony
and Toshiba and Sharp.
But then also the cell phone
novels really aren't anything.
Japan is still -- Japan has not --
they just got the Kindle
two-and-a-half years ago, right?
So Japan's like six
years behind on Kindle.
The publishers were
really against it.
I've never seen a Kindle in public.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Hmm.
>> Sarah Burnes: Wow.
>> Craig Mod: And then iBooks.
I rarely see anyone using
an iPad to read books.
If they are, they're reading comics.
And that's a pragmatic sort
of choice because comics,
they're published weekly in these
things that are like 600 pages
and they look like phonebooks.
And so, you know, 10 years ago
you'd have people reading phonebooks
on the subway.
And they're very disposable.
You're through the phonebook
in, you know, a couple of hours.
And so if you can do that on your
iPad that's a little bit nicer.
But for the most part
bookstores are thriving.
My neighborhood -- I moved in next
to my favorite bookstore
in the world.
It's the most profitable
bookstore in Japan right now.
It opened three years ago,
three-and-a-half years ago.
Just as Borders was closing
here, this bookstore was opening.
This massive --
>> Sarah Burnes: Is it
an independent store?
>> Craig Mod: It's not.
It was a DVD rental company --
>> Sarah Burnes: Oh.
>> Craig Mod: -- that
started doing bookstores.
And they had this like -- this
idea of let's make this kind
of shrine to books and magazines.
>> Sarah Burnes: Mm-hmm.
Sounds good.
>> Craig Mod: And it
worked really well.
And so the Internet in Japan and
literature kind of don't overlap
that much in what I've seen.
And one of my good friends,
Motoyuki Shibata is one
of the pre-eminent translators
of American fiction to Japanese.
He runs this great journal
called Monkey Business .
In the States it's
Monkey Business .
In Japan it's just called Monkey .
And nothing is online.
And they have all these
wonderful -- I keep poking him.
I've been poking him for years
to get this stuff online.
And there just isn't that
desire to get it up there.
So it's a very strange relationship.
But Japan is still very,
very analog on a whole.
>> Sarah Burnes: Yes.
Would you like a mic?
>> Well, I'll try to --
>> Sarah Burnes: Yeah.
Here comes -- here comes one.
>> Thank you.
>> I'm fascinated by --
I'm Bob Darnton [assumed spelling].
I was fascinated by Virginia
Heffernan's characterization
of the New Yorker [laughter]
as a kind of writing that --
from which you have been
liberated to the epitome
of in a way overwriting
by minimizing.
My statistics are probably wrong,
but roughly 310,000 new books were
produced in the U.S. last year
through the normal trade process.
And something like 700,000
were self-published.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
Amazing, yeah.
>> The explosion of
self-publishing is amazing.
I mean its authors
are now everywhere.
Everyone is an author
as you were saying,
and it has a kind of
liberating quality.
So how to formulate
this as a question.
The question is, what
is authorship now?
The New Yorker no longer has
this ultimate seal of approval --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Mm-hmm.
>> -- and there is this liberating
effect that you described.
It's fascinating to hear.
So where are we going?
Are we going to have a world
of different kinds of authors
or everyone being an author?
You know, it used to be said
that books were written
for the general public.
Now they're written
by the general public.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Mm-hmm.
>> So how do you understand this
kind of sociological transformation
of the condition of the author?
>> Virginia Heffernan: I mean to
the extent that the word author has,
you know, authority attached
to it, I do actually --
you know, it's possible that there
will not -- that the terms --
that literature and
authorship still belong
to analog media and to print books.
So I was in my more Bolshevik
for the Internet days
when I was a real -- like I didn't
see anything wrong with like,
you know, the way that
Sovietologists used to be
like Europe will fall and we'll get
rid of all this and -- so that's --
you know, I was like really
impatient with anyone who as
like I don't want to
use a touchscreen.
I was just like you better
get used to it [laughter].
I was on a panel with someone who's
not like that, Nicholson Baker,
who objects so much to digitization
that he even wanted the card catalog
to be preserved just like --
it's a natural for digitization,
frankly, like a numerical system.
But, you know, he missed
the cards and so forth.
And, you know, I was talking very
excitedly about self-publishing,
a lot of which, you know --
I was talking first about publishing
moving to e-books and how great
that was and how we weren't
going to lose anything.
And then I was talking
about self-publishing.
And he said, "Well, would you," you
know, "would you self-publish a book
and then you'd just do it
in e-book form, right?"
And I suddenly was
like, well, my book,
I want in rock and
leather, you know.
I'm like, I want it on a shelf.
And so the author themselves,
you know --
the reading public seems to
be unwilling to pay much more
than $10 or $15 for an e-book.
The authors will pay $40,000 to
do a print run of their own book.
So the one person that
will pay a lot
for a book is the author
themselves because, you know --
my grandfather self-published a book
for his grandchildren,
beautifully printed.
It was called vanity
publishing in those days.
And I'm still not sure
where vanity publishing ends
and self-publishing begins.
I don't know -- I mean,
I'd like to ask Robin
because the KPL was close to --
>> Robin Sloan: Mm-hmm.
>> Virginia Heffernan: -- a little
bit close to self-publishing.
>> Robin Sloan: Mm, totally.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
So didn't you feel like you were
minted when it was made a real book?
You know, that like
that was the moment
that the New Yorker editors
says like you're good enough.
And like the vanity thing --
>> Robin Sloan: Yes.
>> Virginia Heffernan: -- has
to disappear at some point.
>> Robin Sloan: I'll tell you is,
actually, so the short answer is no.
I probably should have
though, and --
because here's what I learned
actually in that process.
I didn't know about this because --
well, because, like you, I was --
and in some ways, in some
respects, I still am such a sort
of Internet patriot, you know?
>> Virginia Heffernan:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: But a native of
and kind of a ardent, you know --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: -- patriot of the
Internet, the Internet Nation.
And so I didn't realize, and
what I didn't really know
about as a civilian
user at that point,
was the intellectual supply
chain and really the set
of social arrangements
that surround, you know,
established publishers and
publishing houses, and libraries,
and bookstores, and all the way that
those things are woven together.
And, I mean, I knew that there was
a social component to publishing
because I knew I had had to promote
my own little self-published thing
online --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yes.
>> Robin Sloan: -- and
tell people about it,
and the fact that I knew
people online or people
who had read me online was
important to its success.
But in retrospect I see that that
was like, you know, if we were going
to draw it on a whiteboard, that
would just be like a little star
with a few spokes, and then I was
suddenly placed in this other system
that was like a dense, rich mesh --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: -- because
it's so old and so established
and it has all these like
interesting feelings and senses
of authority built into it.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: So I think --
>> Sarah Burnes: And you're talking
about booksellers and
salespeople and --
>> Robin Sloan: Exactly, exactly.
>> Sarah Burnes: --
reviewers and the whole --
>> Robin Sloan: NPR.
>> Sarah Burnes: -- the
whole old infrastructure.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: -- agrarians
like the whole system.
I mean, it's like -- it's
a very impressive system
and a very powerful system.
>> Sarah Burnes: Right.
>> Robin Sloan: And so, I
didn't actually understand
that I was being [inaudible] --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Oh, yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: -- kind
of sucked up into that.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Robin Sloan: And it was
only after the book came out
and I like experienced the rush
of that, very sort of slow,
you know, quiet rush from that.
That was like, oh, this
is a powerful thing.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Teah, yeah.
Yeah.
>> Sarah Burnes: I just
want to interject something
about that question and --
Malcolm Cowley once said that,
"A writer is somebody
who has readers."
Which I go back and forth
in thinking that's very wise
and very cynical because
if you've written it
and no one reads it,
are you a writer?
But one of the things that's -- from
vanity publishing to self-publishing
to actual, you know, Random House
publishing, is that the authors
who get the most readers
are the ones who are --
there are different opportunities,
let's put it that way,
to get lots of readers, and for
writers to get lots of readers.
And that -- it's almost
that that's so --
that's very destabilized right
now because it used to be
that the New Yorker
would say read this
or Bennett Cerf would say read
this, and those -- even though --
I love Robin describing the system
because it's a very
robust notion of it.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yes.
>> Sarah Burnes: But
the levers are changing.
>> Craig Mod: Yeah.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Virginia Heffernan: But one
quick thing is Paul Graham,
who started Y Combinator, which
is like just a incubation VC
in San Francisco who
has an enormous amount
of intellectual authority and, you
know, is this like runic source
of wisdom about how to make money.
He [laughter] -- I
talked to him recently
and he had just redesigned
his bio because, you know,
a person like him, the same way
that, you know, Warren Buffett,
half of his mystique is his
prescription for making money
that he writes and
codifies in books.
And then other half is how
he does make the money.
And Paul Graham had
just changed his bio
to say essayist something
and venture capitalist.
>> Craig Mod: Hmm.
>> Virginia Heffernan: And he
was so hard to get on the phone
as a journalist and he was like
so reluctant to tell me anything.
And he's English and he's kind
of intimidating, and at the end
of the call he said, "Do you
think I could get one of my essays
in the New Yorker [laughter]?"
Like that is still an
aspiration, you know [laughter]?
And [laughter], you know, it's like
me wanting the Moroccan leather.
He's so rich.
>> Robin Sloan: He's so rich.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
So he -- yeah, he does --
>> Robin Sloan: He
doesn't need anything.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Right.
You would think he
doesn't need anything.
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah.
>> Virginia Heffernan: But
you cannot buy your way
into the New Yorker and that is --
makes it covetable
by the Elon Musk's
of the world and by
the people who --
>> Craig Mod: And you see this
fettishtization [sic] of that --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Right.
>> Craig Mod: -- rolled in a lot of
the new media startups that have --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Right.
>> Craig Mod: -- popped up recently.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
And by the way,
thank God for the Eastern
establishment
like including the Library of
Congress would have no authority
with those Silicon Valley guys.
They would just like move to Mars
and knock us all out [laughter].
We have to constantly --
>> Craig Mod: I think
it's still happening.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
Yeah, you're right.
But we have to constantly be like --
but there's still something
very important
about the New Yorker [laughter].
>> Sarah Burnes: Sure, of course.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
Oh, yeah, please, yes.
>> Sarah Burnes: You
may have the last word.
>> Oh, no.
I don't want -- but this
is apropos of the DPLA.
So I think the DPLA is developing
a real interest in authorship -
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> -- and has a role in this.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Mm-hmm.
>> And one way this can
happen is through something
that you may not know of
called the Authors Alliance.
So we have created a kind
of voluntary organization
in which authors give over
the use of their copyrights
for open access publishing.
And the DPLA can make
these books available.
It's, I think, crucial for authors
to understand that their books,
if you're talking about
money, which you did bring up,
cease to sell very rapidly.
What is the --
>> Sarah Burnes: Right.
>> -- commercial life
expectancy of a book?
It depends on the field and so
on, but often weeks, months.
Rarely more than years.
So why can't we have a
system in which all kinds
of authors make available
on open access their books.
They're not sacrificing anything
because they don't make money
on the certain point, but
they're getting something.
Mainly, readers and
access to readership.
So that sounds like a commercial.
But I really feel [laughter] --
>> Sarah Burnes: That
was a good one.
>> -- the DPLA has a role to play
in this very interesting new
landscape you've described so well.
>> Sarah Burnes: Great.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
Yeah, I liked that.
>> Sarah Burnes: Are we done?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
So I don't know whether -- if
you can answer this quickly,
but I was just wondering if each
of you had a piece of advice
for a young writer, a young writer,
aspiring author, coming up today.
>> Robin Sloan: I do think I have
come to believe that what books are,
you know, of all sizes and
shapes, digital and analog,
is a set of social arrangements
and social relationships.
>> Sarah Burnes: Right.
>> Robin Sloan: And so I do think
the most valuable thing you could do
is start to build that
little web of your own.
It sounds -- I don't know.
It sounds urbanal and cliched to
say because we just talk so much
about marketing and
self-promotion and things like that.
But it's still the truth, I
think, that the gap between --
talking about readers -- the
gap between like zero readers
and 15 readers, like real
readers, not drive-by people
who found something on the Internet
and then moved on to the next thing.
But people who are
like, oh, I like this.
This is my kind of thing.
Like if you can get from zero to
15 or 35, that's the challenge,
because if you have 35
you can get 60 [laughter].
If you got 60 you could probably get
200, and then, I mean, forget it --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Right.
>> Robin Sloan: -- you know.
Then you're on your way.
So I would say it's -- and it's --
but it's hard to do because
35 readers, you know?
And like you know all of them.
And they're -- like half are
related to you or whatever.
That's not the vision --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Well,
you got to start somewhere.
>> Robin Sloan: That's
not -- you have to.
I guess that's what I would say.
I'd be like start an
e-mail list, add 35 people,
and know that that's the
first like foundation stone
of whatever's going to come --
>> Virginia Heffernan: That's smart.
>> Robin Sloan: -- because
it has to be by definition.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: It's funny how e-mail
feels like the fresh new place.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Mm, mm-hmm.
>> Craig Mod: Right?
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: Like I like
getting -- it's Sunday night.
You talk about the Sunday night
e-mail rush, the mailing list.
Sunday night comes and like all
of my favorite things come --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: -- from
all over the world
from all these different
writers, and it's very weird.
It's like our --
>>
>> Virginia Heffernan:
And they're written.
>> Craig Mod: It's
kind of like our --
>> Virginia Heffernan: The
other thing is they're written.
>> Craig Mod: Yeah.
Like people take it
really seriously.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: You know.
Like a working library, you know?
When she sends out --
>> Sarah Burnes: Virginia,
do you have a newsletter?
>> Virginia Heffernan: I don't.
>> Sarah Burnes: So -- okay.
>> Virginia Heffernan: And
newsletters are it, so --
>> Sarah Burnes: Yeah.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
-- I don't know.
>> Sarah Burnes: Craig and Robin do.
They're very good.
You should subscribe.
>> Virginia Heffernan:
They're really good.
>> Craig Mod: And the Working
Library has a great one, too,
that comes out like
once every six months.
But when it does, it's like --
>> Robin Sloan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: Yeah.
They spend so much time
on it, so much love.
>> Virginia Heffernan: So the book
is called Magic and Loss , my book.
And -- coming out in June.
And the magic is what I described
as the sort of Bolshevik thing.
The loss is, I think, the loss --
the sense of grief
that all of us feel,
not just like culture
elites or, you know,
people left out of the digital
divide in this digital revolution.
And I now believe that a
young writer, if maybe --
this sounds like jargon, but to
get in touch with the part of her
that feels -- that
resists digitization.
So, you know, the
-- like you talked
about the social relationships,
we've had, you know,
an online relationship for a while.
But when I saw you, it's so funny
because the Internet has jacked
up the values of personal
interactions.
So it's like, you know, we could
just be meeting as two panelists
who kind of knew each other's work.
But instead it's like, you
know, we hugged each other hello.
You know, we've never
met in person.
Because like suddenly the
human body is like, you know,
it's like the critically
and scariest says
like we think imagination is so
great and then you compare the dry,
you know, imagination to like
the sensory emotional world
of like bodies, you know?
The Navy is training people
with sextants and compasses
and celestial navigation now
because they fear an attack on GPS.
If we make all of our interactions
of the physical world based
in abstract maps, then we,
you know, have lost the role
of like magnets and
stars and so get in touch
with earlier technologies like
printing and find the part of you
that is, you know, is -- that
loves leather or loves live music
and not mp3's or whatever because
not only will that affect the medium
that you work in but also
that's your story to tell.
That's your story, you know?
That's that particular
kind of exquisite pain is,
I think, a wonderful narrative.
At least I can't get enough of it.
>> Craig Mod: Hmm.
I would just say, sort of
to your point, Virginia,
like don't be afraid of technology.
And, in fact, the most interesting
intersections, I think, of writing
or creating or authorship
today are happening
with these weird fuzzy
boundaries of tech and printing.
One of my favorite examples
is a photographer/artist,
Mishka Henner, a British
photographer.
And he's kind of come to light
in the last five or six years
because he started printing
out Google Map satellite photos.
Like that was his thing.
And so like he'd go and find
all of the U.S. hidden army bases
around the world on Google
Maps, and then print that out
and call it like 51 bases.
Or doing other things
with print on demand.
And it was funny.
It was like the printing
of the stuff --
like he'd collate these
collections of photos.
But it was the printing that
allowed like the Tate to acquire it.
And the Tate acquiring
it was the thing
that allowed him to
be a real artist.
>> Virginia Heffernan: Mm-hmm.
>> Craig Mod: And that allowed
him all these other affordances.
But it was only because he was
willing to play in this kind
of space of like well,
what is photography?
Well, photography is, you know,
being interested in
light and imagery.
And, well, what if I use
Google Maps to find these things
or Google Street View to find,
you know, people that are kind
of accidently in these
collections of data?
And if I take that, draw a box
around it, give it the boundaries,
and then use cheap print on
demand to put it out in the world
as an artifact -- like that's --
it sounds simple but that's
actually quite a few like kind
of like jumps to make and
willingness to experiment.
And I think that like
his body of work
and the recognition he's got is
a great example of what happens
when you start to
play in that space.
>> Virginia Heffernan: I love it.
>> Craig Mod: So I think there's --
>> Virginia Heffernan: Yeah.
>> Craig Mod: -- lots
of opportunity there.
>> Sarah Burnes: Thank
you guys so much.
We could go for another
hour-and-a-half,
but we're already over time.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.